sixteen years ago wii sports changed how
people interact with games and who those
people are its release was a pivotal
point in gaming history and culture when
everyone and their mother often quite
literally was playing the game wii
sports captured an unadulterated sense
of fun that was seldom scenic games at
the time that appealed to such a broad
demographic nintendo switch sports a
successor of sorts attempts to recapture
the same feeling of standing in a room
and brazenly swinging around your limbs
to act out a sport while you compete
with your friends and family during my
hands-on time with nintendo switch
sports i consistently lost a volleyball
but managed to wreck my opponent at
badminton and regardless of my success i
was having a blast at one point during
my 45 minutes of hands-on time with the
game i stood in a room with two nintendo
representatives as we bowled together in
an all-new simultaneous mode these
people were strangers to me but in that
moment i laughed with them teased them
when they didn't pick up a spare and
cheered when they got a strike
it
was a ton of fun
there was even one moment when all three
of us got a strike at the same time
sending us into a collective war even
though we were still competing against
one
this is the kind of joy that wii sports
brought to living rooms around the world
and what nintendo switch sports
encapsulates once more nintendo switch
sports already feels like a complete
package which is a contrast to the
original wii sports that although very
fun felt more like a proof of concept
for the wii's motion controller than a
full-fledged product nintendo switch
sports iterates on what came before by
building on wii sports and its successor
wii sports resorts this is apparent in
the game's character models which are
more akin to splatoon's inklings and
their fashionable fits than the
rudimentary designs of me's don't worry
though the iconic me's are still
available to use for your avatar in fact
nintendo switch sports as a whole from
its setting to the character models of
those taking part shares a striking
resemblance to splatoon's stylized
aesthetic and even as a wii sports
purist i'm cool with it from the very
start of the preview it was clear that
nintendo switch sports was more
deliberate in its setting and aesthetic
than previous installments i could
choose from one of six sports that were
displayed over the map of a detailed
sports center called spoko square each
sport takes place in a realistic and
stylized environment within the hub like
the volleyball court outside the cafe
bookstore overlooked by a modern city
skyline the first stop was tennis which
felt like returning to wii sports in a
very natural way within moments the
timing of the hits came back to me as i
was in the heat of little cartoon people
furiously launching the ball back and
forth the improvement of the switch
version comes from the additional
accuracy afforded by the joy-con
smacking the ball with a twist of the
wrist and seeing it spin to the other
side just felt great a delightful thrill
tinged with a little nostalgia badminton
meanwhile was a challenging change of
pace nintendo switch sports managed to
capture the energetic back and forth and
frantic nature of badminton very well
unlike tennis which just asks the player
to swing the joy con badminton uses gyro
motion and has the player utilize full
motion of their arm for more precise
aiming in hitting the shuttle [ __ ] each
round was an intense dance as my
opponent and i swatted the birdie at one
another looking for an opening and
opportunity to catch the other off
balance after a long ballet of volleys
lightly tapping the birdie over the nets
at the perfect moment and watching my
opponent's avatar flail and fumble to
reach it before it hit the ground was
incredibly satisfying after a sweaty
match of badminton we played chimbara
nintendo switch sports his version of
wii sports resorts swordplay chambara
follows the same basic rule as swords
play two players stand in a ring seeking
to overthrow each other and whoever is
knocked off the ledge first loses
allowing each player to choose from
sword charge sword or twin swords which
requires the player to use both joy cons
for this hands on we went toe to toe
with a single sword only coming right
off the desperate flailing of badminton
chambara was slow and methodical it
required me to carefully observe my
opponent's sword and its position which
led to a tense standoff with
opportunistic strikes knocking each
closer to the ledge these moments were
punctuated by swift comebacks and climax
and triumphant victories or woeful
losses
again in both cases it was exhilarating
and most importantly
fun
then there was volleyball which required
constant change of the kind of physical
movement i was doing with my arms in
moment-to-moment gameplay i went from
bumping to blocking to jumping and
spiking my avatar moved automatically
around the court changing positions
based on the ball's movement which meant
i was entirely focused on what move to
use next
thankfully the game signaled whether i
should bump block or spike in the corner
of the screen to make it a bit easier it
felt a little difficult to adjust to at
first but i'm sure after a few rounds
i'd get the hang of it
in the short time i had however i walked
away from volleyball feeling like it
wasn't as intuitive or as approachable
as the other sports
of the six sports the most compelling
and possibly most flawed is soccer it
features the most intricate controls
which are more relative to a traditional
sports game in the 1v1 or 4v4 modes two
joy-cons are required for each player so
they can have full control over moving
the avatar around the field as opposed
to avatars moving independently in other
modes while also having buttons for
sprinting and jumping in order to kick
the ball players have to swing either
controller in the direction they want to
kick it for me what ensued was a big
deviation from other sports i had
experienced instead of my avatar
standing in place with me as the player
using a single joy-con act out motions i
was put into a more focused state of
play as i maneuver my avatar around an
open field kicking a giant rocket league
size ball
i had to jump and swing the controller
upward to give the ball more air
left or right to get it out of an
opponent's reach or swipe both joy cons
down at the same time to launch my
character head first into the action all
of that sounds great on paper but
despite the extra functionality and more
in-depth control scheme i found it to
feel unnaturally slow and tedious
getting my player to run towards the
ball which put a damper on the
excitement of the action
still the mode has potential to become
something exciting by having a higher
skill ceiling than the rest of the
sports involved i can envision playing
online with a group of friends using
planned tactics and precise executions
that could lead to exciting prospects
and i hope that it clicks with me
eventually so i can have that experience
but for now
soccer left me a little underwhelmed
also in soccer there was one shot mode
which was the only mode to feature the
use of the joy-con like strap the same
one used with ring fit adventure in this
mode i strapped a joycon to my leg and
had to kick a receiving ball into the
goal with each successful goal the point
of entry for the ball to go into the net
narrowed more and more as the ball
changed variables like speed or adding
spin requiring me to be more precise
with the timing and execution of the
kick
a leg strap is required to play this
mode so if you don't have one or plan to
purchase nintendo switch sports
digitally keep that in mind thankfully
only one strap is required even for two
players the most apparent absent from
the list of sports from me was boxing
boxing in the original was the height of
wii sports jankiness and the pure joy
that can come from a weird and wacky
motion controlled mini game i'd love to
see what boxing could be like in
nintendo switch sports with the joy cons
motion tech in the meantime chambara is
a suitable 1v1 combat replacement even
though i wasn't thrilled with volleyball
or soccer i still walked away with an i
can't wait to play this game with my
partner and friends sense of excitement
and excitingly there was a lot i didn't
see each sport has different modes and
difficulties that i didn't get to
interact with i also didn't have the
chance to delve into character
customization and unlockable cosmetics
or online play which features several
additional modes including 16 players
bowling but in the meantime with the
game and the six sports i played i saw a
lot that would satisfy those looking for
a wii sports replacement for the modern
era nintendo switch sports is shaping up
to be a welcome return for nintendo
classic
[Applause]
okay